[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
francia 24 y ya me acompaña hoy viernes
de rosa pérez masdéu para repasar lo más
importante de la prensa internacional la
rosa bienvenida entonces a nuestra mesa
de trabajo muy buen día ya estamos a
viernes y abrimos entonces esta revista
de prensa con las portadas de eeuu que
detallan las conclusiones de la última
audiencia pública sobre este asalto al
capitolio el pasado 6 de enero de 2021
vamos entonces con el washington post
del new york times el washington y el
boston globe bueno es de a raúl
exactamente y las distintas portadas van
un poco en la línea que como bien me
comentabas intentaba trazar esta última
audiencia pública y es la
responsabilidad de donald trump del ex
presidente estadounidense de no frenar
la el asalto al capitolio durante
187 minutos básicamente se le acusa de
estar mirando a través de la televisión
lo que sucedía en el capitolio y estos a
187 minutos fueron los que pasaron entre
su discurso en now washington en el que
insistió en el fraude electoral y
digamos de ahí se desprendió y pidió de
hecho a los manifestantes que fueran al
capitolio para evitar impedir la
certificación de joe biden como
presidente de eeuu y cuando digamos ya
finalmente pidió a través de la
televisión que el agente se fuera hacia
sus casas bien en todo caso washington
post dice trump ignoró varias peticiones
o súplicas depende de como hagamos la
traducción de que actuará súplicas o
peticiones tanto por parte de su familia
como de altos funcionarios y consejeros
de la casa blanca por otro lado el new
york times dice los testigos detallan
como trump se negó a detener el asalto
del 6 de enero por otro lado wall street
journal el panel escrito la inacción de
trump respecto al motín y el boston
globe trump rechazó desmovilizar el
ataque dicen al panel bien en todo caso
el escenario que se dibuja es el de una
violación del juramento presidencial que
habría hecho donald trump en el 2016 en
todo caso en octubre como bien decía
saldrá la hay resolución final de este
panel vamos a ver si trump acaba
imputado penalmente también por estos
hechos y si esto le permite o le impide
presentarse a las elecciones de 2024
como parece ser su intención rosa
pasamos ahora a la prensa de brasil que
abre casi unánimemente con la operación
policial que dejó 18 personas fallecidas
en la ciudad de río de janeiro
exactamente tal y como nos señala el
medio el país la policía de brasil es
una de las más letales del mundo y de
hecho no sé si recuerdan que aquí en
esta sección comentamos una reportaje
que analizaba como la integración de
cámaras de seguridad corporales en la
policía de sao paulo en la publicidad
militar de sao paulo había reducido en
más de un 50% las muertes a manos de la
policía militar no del estado de sao
paulo y es alguna de las medidas que se
intentan implementar para reducir la
tasa de homicidios a manos de la policía
de brasil en todo caso esto sucedió en
el río de janeiro y vamos a comentar
algunos de los medios de brasil y cómo
lo titulan por un lado extra este medio
río titula una nueva tragedia de una
guerra sin fin dice los habitantes de
alemao vivieron un nuevo día de miedo no
12 horas de esta operación militar de
operación de la policía militar contra
una banda de narcotráfico y de distintos
digamos materiales de contrabando dice
la operación en un barrio de favelas se
vieron en blindados helicópteros
etcétera y 18 personas resultaron
muertas entre ellas una mujer dentro de
un auto precisamente en globo vemos una
imagen de una vecina con una bandera
blanca no pidiendo el final de la
violencia
titulado globo miedo dolor y 18 muertos
y de hecho testifica en este medio la
pareja de la mujer que murió en el coche
diciendo estábamos en mi casa empeña en
otro barrio en otro barrio de río y
vinimos aquí al complejo de alemao a
desayunar con mi tía en ese momento se
desató el tiroteo paramos en un semáforo
y al poco dispararon a mi coche le
dieron en el pecho por otro lado la
folha de sao paulo operación de policía
mata al menos a 18 personas y en él
correio braziliense finalmente este
párrafo es bastante contundente sus
tiros de ametralladoras batería
antiaérea contra helicópteros blindados
personas desesperadas cuerpos por las
calles escenas que acostumbran a
caracterizar las guerras fueron vistas
en una comunidad pobre de río de janeiro
bueno rosa cerramos con uno de estos
casos en que la realidad como se dice
supera la ficción una escena en la
televisión británica que se ha realizado
por la comparación con apple y con una
película john woodcock que no mires
hacia arriba traduce si en español que
la también la protagoniza leonardo
dicaprio exactamente y esta película
utiliza la metáfora de una llegada de un
meteorito a la tierra para compararla
con el cambio climático y la inacción de
los distintos poderosos poderes
particularmente el mediático básicamente
esta película se ha comparado con la
escena que tuvo lugar el 14 de julio en
la televisión living news que se compara
con la cadena fox pero de reino unido en
que una presentadora digamos de turner
se rió un poco un poco de john hammond
un meteorólogo que intenta advertir
sobre las consecuencias letales
la ola de calor que esperaba al reino
unido esta semana precisamente
recordemos que reino unido superó y
marcó su récord de temperatura con 40,3
grados celsius veamos rápidamente este
fragmento que fue un montaje del usuario
de twitter janis las íes pero del que se
ha hecho eco incluso el 'washington
post'
bueno les estamos intentando decir que
el planeta entero está a punto de ser
destruido
bueno ya sabes lo que hacemos aquí
mantener las malas noticias un poco
ligeras
hola a todos nos gusta el buen tiempo
pero esto no es buen tiempo será un
clima potencialmente letal por un par de
días será breve pero mental
jon aún pero yo quiero que estemos
felices por este tiempo no sé qué les
pasa a los meteorólogos que todos están
un poco fatalistas mensajeros de la
fatalidad porque en todas las cadenas de
televisión particularmente en la bbc
cada vez que enciendo el televisor y
alguien habla sobre el tiempo dicen que
va a haber toneladas de muertes pero no
hemos tenido calor siempre en verano
jong el verano del 76 fue tan caluroso
como este no pues después después ned
y cada vez hay más y más récords más
frecuentes y más severos como se debe
rosa muchísimas gracias por revista de
prensa nos vemos el lunes descanse el
fin de semana pasamos a saludar a
nuestra primera invitada al día